[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire et la gag ça n'est pas le
bon prompteur donc il nous faut la
côte autre chose on
nota promoteurs de cette accolade
voilà c'est le promoteur ça nous trompe
tard donc je vais tâcher de rappeler
ce que je voulais vous dire on va faire
une émission sur la présidentielle
sachant que les sondages aujourd'hui
nous disent que et bagnols macron
devrait sortir premiers en tête du mois
au 1er tour ah bah voilà il arrive le
vrai il l'emporterait également au
second dans tous les cas de figure mais
face à qui suspense marine le pen eric
zemmour et xavier bertrand serait dans
un mouchoir de poche l'a dit madame x
serait plutôt en faveur d'eric zemmour
du côté de la gauche plus grand monde ne
croit à l'union les sept candidats
déclarés se partageraient 30% des
intentions de vote yannick jadot compris
donc zéro chance d'accéder au second
tour mais bon tout ça ces légumes des
choses regardons la mère qui est en
dessous le clivage gauche droite est il
encore opérationnels et la lutte des
classes et le populisme qu'est-ce qui
oppose le bloc ma chronique à ses
adversaires
existe-t-il un bloc populaire
existe-t-il la possibilité d'une
candidature dissidente comme celle
d'eric zemmour alliant les classes
populaires à la bourgeoisie patriotes
pour en débattre nous avons donc invité
jérôme sainte-marie spécialiste des
études d'opinion directeur de pôle inbox
société d'études et de conseil vous
enseignez à l'institut catholique de
paris vous êtes l'auteur de bloc contre
bloc la dynamique du maquereau nisme
séparés en 2019 aujourd'hui vous publiez
bloc populaire une subversion électorale
inachevés ou vous décrivez face aux
blocs élitaire un bloc populaire encore
à l'état de potentialités mais qui
dispose d'une large base sociale pour la
prochaine présidentielle vous pensez que
ce sera toujours la lutte des classes
bloc contre bloc oui je pense que pour
l'instant on sera assez peu compté on
voit bien qu'il ya une tentative de
restaurer le clivage gauche droite mais
lorsqu'on va arriver au moment du
véritable choix les intérêts matériels
nouvelle fois vont être mis sur la table
et je pense qu'effectivement les
réalités des classes sociales va de
nouveau se réveiller se manifester et
que donc on va de nouveau vers une
opposition entre un bloc élitaire bien
constituer parce qu'il est au pouvoir et
probablement l'expression d'un bloc
populaire jeu fera le jeune vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction du magazine
valeurs actuelles en 2015 vous aviez
écrit une politique fiction intitulée
une élection ordinaire dans laquelle
eric zemmour était élu président de la
république là vous venez de sortir
zemmour président de la fiction à la
réalité toujours aux éditions ring le
livre contient également le roman paru
il ya cinq ans qu'elle est peu
opposition vous voyez à l'oeuvre vous
quelles lignes de fracture écoutez moi
je pense que la dynamique de zemmour
peut s'expliquer par une seule raison
c'est qu'il est en train d'essayer de
faire de cette élection un référendum
pour ou contre l'immigration en fait je
m'explique en quelques phrases il a
décidé d'imposer ce débat dans la
présidentielle pour l'instant il a
plutôt réussi médiatiquement et même au
delà de l'effet médiatique en réalité on
voit bien que la question identitaire en
règle générale est en train de de
traverser le débat public en permanence
voilà que les candidats se positionne
par rapport à lui on voit la droite se
radicalise et on voit emmanuel macron
taper sur l'algérie sur la question des
visas etc donc il est en train d'imposer
cette thématique et je pense je pense
sinon moi je souhaite mais mais mais je
vois aussi arriver arrivé dans banc dans
cette élection cette question de
l'immigration comme point central et je
pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
une raison simple c'est que en réalité
c'est un phénomène social extrêmement
important qui a changé le le visage de
la france en vendant quelques décennies
et que en réalité les français n'ont
jamais voté pour savoir quelle devait
être la politique d'immigration de la
france alors on nous dira que oui le pen
a incarné ça et que les gens n'ont pas
voté pour lui ça en attendant ça n'a été
à aucun moment l'élément central de
décision pour une action présentiel et
je pense que peut-être pour la première
fois ça peut être le cas et que c'est ce
qui porte aujourd'hui eric zemmour qui a
dont la candidature a de multiples
défauts mais ça le porte aujourd'hui aux
15 16 ou 17 % qu'on voit dans les
sondages c'est la seule raison je pense
pour laquelle il est porté aujourd'hui
catherine tricot vous êtes architecte
urbaniste mais vous êtes également la
directrice de regard le site et la revue
fondée par secours ouvriers en 1928 du
communiste à partir de 1933 c'est à
l'époque le temple du photojournalisme
ça s'est interrompue entre 1962 et 1995
je vous en avais été la rédactrice en
chef à partir de 2011 en est à présent
la directrice alors vous quelle force
voyez-vous à l'oeuvre quelle quelle
opposition
oui je pense qu'un a plusieurs qui sont
en train de se de s'esquisser celle que
vous venez de dire notamment sur la
question identité métissage qui est un
premier en première ligne de partage moi
je crois que quand on a une très forte
qui va émerger c'est est ce qu'il ya un
avenir vert au fond quelles sont les
perspectives d'avenir c'est à dire que
ce ne sont pas que des questions à mon
avis matériel ou de classe mais de
projet je pense que pour l'instant il
n'y a pas de projet très fort qui émerge
à gauche mais il y en a en a un qui me
semblent commencer à se structurer qui
est un projet technophiles dire qu'ils
pensent qu'on va s'en sortir notamment
sur le plan du changement climatique
grâce à des inventions à l'eau nucléaire
et c'est qu'on va régler le problème des
migrations grâce au fil de fer barbelé
virtuel aux caméras etc et je crois
qu'il ya une alternative à ce discours
technophiles qui peut émerger qui n'est
pas mon avis très constitué mais qui
devrait être la force de la gauche est à
dire un avenir possible commun pour la
france pour les français pour l'humanité
et que sais tu ce discours est cher la
gauche n'a pas travaillé depuis 20 ans
mais le paye le paye mais
c'est à mon avis la seule solution de se
sortir de cette ce désespoir et ce
discours
noirissime qu'on nous qu'on nous dépeint
alors première question est ce que le
bloc macro nist celui que vous appelez
le bloc élitaire est-ce qu'il est sûr de
l'emporter sur vous ça m'arrive je
constate tu fasses et pragmatique au
départ jusqu'à ma sondeurs si vous
voulez donc je regarde les étapes
d'opinion successifs en essayant de
comprendre comment ça peut évoluer tout
pour l'instant je vois simplement que ce
bloc élitaire a bien transformer en
train de traverser pardon le quinquennat
qu'en plus il y avait une dynamique
comment dirais-je une dialectique tout
simplement qui faisait que face à lui se
constituer pape peu à peu un bloc
populaire au gré des réformes et des
mouvements sociaux que ces réformes
provoquer et on a bien vu au monde et
gilet jaune également et que la pandémie
a été une très bonne nouvelle finalement
pour emmanuel macron ça a complètement
gelé le courant de réformes et donc ça a
également complètement gelé la
protestation sociale qui s'exprimait
contre lui dans les sondages emmanuel
macron est un président impopulaire mais
dans des proportions très raisonnables
s'il veut se dire par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs dans actuellement au
premier tour il est redevenu premier
graphe précisément à la présence d'eric
zemmour et puis au second tour il
emporte de manière variable mais face à
tous les candidats il apparaît comme une
comme seulement à présent de garantie
n'a un pays qui vieillit il n'est pas
exclu effectivement qu'il puisse être
reconduit dans sa formule ni gauche ni
droite ou plutôt et gauche et droite
même avis geoffrey lejeune moi je
souscris depuis des années elle a la
démonstration de jérôme sainte-marie sur
le bloc et lutter contre le bloc
populaire néanmoins pour répondre à
votre question sur emmanuel macron je
suis d'accord sur le fait que emmanuel
macron et le meilleur champion du bloc
élitaire ça c'est incontestable vous
l'aviez expliqué d'ailleurs à l'époque
dans l'heure actuelle sur la question
des gie des joueurs qui en réalité a été
une manière pour lui de ressouder son
électorat et des élections européennes
ont ôté la preuve qu'en fait comme il
s'appelle emmanuel macron avait avait
réussi à garder son électorat à ce
moment là alors ça a un peu changé il a
perdu à gauche mais en gagnant à droite
etc mais je suis d'accord même pour dire
que c'est un peu un vote de classe
peut-être que c'est l'électorat le plus
homogène socialement de toute l'offre
politique je suis d'accord avec tout ça
maintenant si vous regardez le l'état
des lieux aujourd'hui il est aux
alentours de 23 24 peut-être 25% au
premier tour ce qui est assez peu en
réalité pour un président en exercice
moi je me mets à sa place
il va avoir une déclaration de
candidature en général on perd des
points à ce moment là ensuite il va être
confronté à la question de son bilan on
perd aussi des points au moment où on a
cet exercice de défense à faire pendant
la campagne c'est assez compliqué la
position de président candidat est assez
compliqué je rappelle juste hors
cohabitation aucun n'a été réélu sous la
vème république c'est quand même une
donnée qui n'est pas à négliger
pour toutes ces raisons là je me dis
c'est pas si facile que ça et il part de
très bas il faut pas oublier qu'en 2017
au moment de son triomphe il est élu
parce que la france est soumise rappelle
à juste titre tout le temps 17% des
inscrits seulement 24% des électeurs 17%
des inscrits à l'origine le maquereau
nisme c'est quelque chose d'assez
d'assez faible dans l'opinion française
vous ajoutez à ça maintenant la question
de son opposition parce qu'il peut
gagner par défaut et la question de son
opposition on a une opposition le bloc
populaire marine le pen moi je pense
pour plein de raisons pour en parler si
vous voulez que elle est encore limitée
par cette question du plafond de verre
mais malgré tout elle existe est
aujourd'hui la question d'eric zemmour
qui change quelque chose dans un
contexte où examen les portés par une
dynamique on la voit depuis quelques
semaines même si en ce moment elle se
tasse un peu je pense qu'il n'est pas
tout à fait exclu que eric zemmour
puisse détacher une partie du bloc
élitaire et ça pour le coup jérôme je
demande votre assentiment la nuit non
mais c'est vrai c'est un électorat très
diplômés très urbain est très aisé et
zemmour et si zemmour fait la jonction
est très âgé bien sûr on aimerait bien
et masculin aussi mais ça c'est moins
vrai c'est beau non ça fait dévier quoi
ça fait pas ça change pas grand chose à
ma démonstration
je veux dire je ne lui ai pas dit que je
les nie absolument pas ce que je veux
dire c'est que je n'ai c'est une manière
de décocher de détacher une partie du
bloc évitèrent cirque en fait emmanuel
macron est friable je trouve et je
constate aujourd'hui que finalement pour
quelqu'un qu'on annonce réélu à tous les
coups dans tous les cas de figure et
pour des raisons évidentes il l'est dans
tous les sondages finalement ça peut
être un bar un parcours du combattant
quand même alors réaction de 4 entre
couilles pour les cheveux moi j'ai une
impression qu emmanuel macron a de
bonnes chances d'être réélu parce que je
crois que marine le pen sera devant eric
zemmour parce qu'elle est mort on va
finir par y lille et pouvant tout le
monde est d'une certaine manière il
recentre marine le pen non qui la rend
presque acceptable dans l'est dans les
milieux de la gauche que vous fréquentez
assez peu on se dit on va finir par
voter marine le pen pour faire barrage
donc ce que je veux dire c'est que je
pense qu'il va finalement il est très
utile parce qu'il permet de la recentrer
de la normalité de la banaliser et
calais quand même confronté au plafond
de verre donc marine le pen emmanuel
macron ça fera pas de ça fera pas le
match quant à emmanuel macron ce que je
pense c'est que il bénéficie de la
faiblesse très très grande de la gauche
tout le monde sait que son électorat
s'est déplacé donc on pourrait penser
que la gauche s'en retrouve conforter
mais c'est pas vrai pourquoi même que
aujourd'hui elle peut encore s'affaiblir
puisque près de lamu d'un électeur sur
deux de gauche c'est un peu variable
selon eux mélenchon ou anne hidalgo mais
enfin les électeurs de gauche ont près
d'un sur deux sont prêts à se dire
qu'ils pourraient voter pour emmanuel
masson pour faire barrage à l'extrême
droite zemmour ou le pen ce qui me
paraît assez
fantastique comme idée puisque toute
façon il est il est dit qu'il serait au
deuxième tour mais ça veut dire que la
gauche est quand même très très très
très faible et que du coup ça lui donne
encore de la réserve il a encore cette
réserve vous de voir face à une de
droite et une extrême droite qui sont
relativement en forme donc ça me désole
à j'avoue que je sais pas assez de
scénario que je préfère jérôme où il en
est dans une période un peu particulière
c'est à dire on a un peu en apesanteur
politique actuellement s'en rend pas
compte parce que nous tous ici on est
passionné par la politique et on se
projette sans cesse sur les échéances
qui viennent mais actuellement seuls 48%
des français d'après opinionway
déclarent s'intéresser à la campagne et
6 48% à mon avis sont moins nombreux il
ya une forme de politesse des sondés qui
dirige m'intéresse parce que bon voilà
mais ça à peu sur une exigence sociale
et beaucoup de gens sont pas vraiment là
dedans donc le les choses sont très
ouvertes heures moi je suis
effectivement j'ai quand même une part
d'hésitation par rapport à ma grille de
lecture principale c'est
qu'effectivement je ne m'attendais pas à
un tel succès de l'ère de la candidature
même dans ce climat un peu virtuel où
c'est comme les csp + les hommes les
personnes âgées qui s'interdit gens
politisés que s'intéresse le plus ça ça
pèse quand même sur les sondages sont
réalisés actuellement mais malgré tout
cela je ne pensais pas qu'on irait au
delà de 7 8% et là effectivement ce je
ne disais c'est 15 ou 17 parfois les
devants par foyer derrière on pourra en
discuter mais c'est pas et ce n'est pas
celle ci est important on mesure quand
même avec cette candidature au delà du
talent particulier qu'on peut c'est un
terme neutre donc d'eric zemmour on
mesure quand même le degré d'angoissé
existentielle d'une bonne partie de la
population française ce cette angoisse
là est ce qu'elle va pas changer durant
à la campagne d'une part parce qu'elle
être stimulée par la campagne elle-même
et puis il ya des questions qui n'ont
pas encore été abordés qui vont arriver
c'est la question notamment de l'avenir
de l'état c'est la question de l'avenir
de la souveraineté est ce qu'on va être
dissous pas alors du prochain
quinquennat dans définitivement dans des
daims dans le cas des traités
internationaux et de l'europe la crise
de l'état est un sujet très sérieux
d'autant plus qu'elle est rendue encore
plus aiguë par le niveau exceptionnel de
l'endettement donc tout cela va peser
donc je suis effectivement je trouve que
le bloc élitaire se comporte pas mal
mais je vous conseille à tous les deux
que il ya une incertitude qui tient au
fait que non seulement il ya l'usure du
pouvoir du premier quinquennat et
surtout la perspective du second c'est à
dire des réformes des privatisations
notamment par je pense au système de
santé qui peuvent être très brutal des
le remboursement de cette dette qui va
faire peur à tout le monde aux
contribuables aisés comme aux catégories
populaires
ils vont pas le payer par disparition de
services publics par exemple et
effectivement on peut avoir une montée
des angoisses face à cela à partir de là
il ya plusieurs options possibles je
pense que l'option d'un point de vue
tout à fait neutre pour le coup le reste
est ce que je défends depuis des années
c'est à dire l'idée que ce bloc
populaire qui peut se constituer mais
qui dépend d'une volonté excusez-moi
parenté dans la parenthèse quand je
parle de classe sociale pour moi elle
existe et elle existe en soi est plus ou
moins subjectivement un bloc historique
populaire où il y terre sur le modèle de
gramsci ça dépend d'une volonté
politique qui se construit pas tout seul
et maquereau a su et les forces sociales
qui le soutiennent assure le construire
mais ça s est encore une fois c'est une
démarche volontariste qu'il a abouti
pour cette démarche elle n'a pas
exactement son équivalent du côté du
bloc populaire
l'expression la moins imparfaite que je
trouve actuellement à cette notion là ça
serait effectivement plus tôt marine le
pen avec articulations du thème national
et du thème disons plus populaire des
prix de préoccupations sociales mais ça
peut être que ça peut résister à une
autre concurrence uniquement centré sur
cette peur existentielle que je
qualifierais pas d'identitaires c'était
trop connoté cette place une espèce
d'angoissé patriotique c'est
effectivement un autre pari je pensais
pas qu'il était aussi jouable que ce que
je constate actuellement
oui geoffroy non mais c'est vrai que en
fait c'est toujours un décalage entre
leur moi je suis pas secondaire mais ça
que je suis passionné par les études et
j'ai beaucoup lu jérôme pour cette
raison en fait il ya toujours un
décalage entre ce que ce que veut
l'opinion française et la manière dont
ça se traduit électoralement c'est en
fait on sait que la question leurs
moyens aux critères c'est pas connotée
je veux dire c'est au sens la question
de l'identité la question d'identité en
fait elle fait relativement les manies
de l'humanité il ya quelques temps un
institut j'ai oublié lequel a demandé
aux français je pense que c'était hélas
vous allez me corriger quelles étaient
leurs sentiments vis-à-vis du grand
emplacement et on constate que 67%
d'entre eux le grand emplacement thème
connoté s'il en est est quasiment
interdit de cité dans le débat public et
c'est parce qu'il a été inventé par
renaud camus 67% des français disent
qu'ils sont inquiets de ce phénomène
donc ça veut dire que c'est en fait très
rassembleur finalement quand même
représentation qui était fait je ne sais
plus quel monde l'institut mais je sais
que la présentation qui a été faite de
cette notion polémique de grands
emplacements étaient particulièrement
dures donc que les gens aient adhéré à
ça m'avait dit fais moi assez
impressionné mais en réalité ça fait
quinze ans que quand on collectionne les
enquêtes chaque année celle du cevipof
sur l'état de l'opinion et s'est
consacré une forme de radicalisation de
l'opinion donc pour cette raison là il y
aurait une majorité il y aurait une
potentiellement une majorité électorale
à faire sur cette question mais en fait
c'est les forces politiques qui peuvent
l'incarner sont tellement et parce que
finalement ça samsam aboutie jamais donc
peut-être que zemmour est en train de
changer la donne et qu' il va finir par
catalyse et tout ça et qu'il est porté
par ce courant et que ça le le porter
encore plus haut je m'en sers moi ce que
j'écoute dans ce que vous dites est ce
que je questionne c'est la capacité de
marine le pen qui a choisi une autre
stratégie en réalité à incarner une
alternative à et maniable et je vous
promets qu'après je parlais de la gauche
que ça m'intéresse également
mais en fait d'ailleurs j'y viens marine
le pen a choisi dès 2012 d'ailleurs elle
venait d'hériter du parti de son père
elle avait fait une première candidature
à la présidentielle et elle se retrouve
en situation de commencer son aventure
politique elle échoue aux portes du
second tour et et c'est pas humiliant à
l'époque et elle choisit au lieu de
tendre la main aux électeurs de droite
déçus par part par la défaite de nicolas
sarkozy l'arrivée du socialiste françois
hollande etc elle choisi de tendre la
main aux électeurs de mélenchon plutôt
pour essayer justement constituer ce que
vous appelez de vos voeux c'est à dire
cette majorité enfin c'est ce bloc
populaire et en fait ça fait dix ans
qu'elle essaye et ça fait dix ans que ça
ne fonctionne pas moi c'est ça que je
questionne ça fait dix ans que l a
progressé un temps et elle a plafonné et
en 2017 on a compris que ça ne la
portait 4 33% des voix et depuis elle
régresse aux municipales elle régresse
en nombre de voix alors oui d'abstention
vient tempérer tout cette analyse mais
et aux régionales aussi et elle s'en
sort moins bien que d'autres partis donc
ma question c'est finalement il ya un
affrontement entre deux intellectuels
qui sont jérôme sainte marie et patrick
buisson c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui en
jeu mais c'est vrai et patrick buisson
pendant des années je sais qu'après il a
changé d'avis il est venu sur votre
ligne mais il a expliqué que la droite
ne pouvait gagner que si elle faisait
l'alliance justement de la bourgeoisie
patriotes dont parle eric zemmour et des
classes populaires d'autres comme vous
prétendre que le bloc populaire peut
suffire jeu j'aimerais juste comprendre
dans quelle mesure sa fin sur quoi vous
fondez pour penser ça parce qu'en
réalité quand on voit la stratégie de
marine le pen finalement je trouve que l
est de moins en moins en mesure
d'accéder et l'arrivée de zemmour le
prouve une fois de plus d'accéder aux
responsabilités
à cause de cette stratégie alors je
laisserais jérôme sainte-marie répondent
mais juste après avoir posé une question
à quatre entre co parce que j'ai là on
est sur quelque chose que l'on appelle
les identitaires il y aurait un bloc
identitaire même si lui aussi les
disséminer et j'ai l'impression que
c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya encore une
gauche c'est celle qui mena des repas
oui c'est pas ça c'est pas faux alors
même si des individus ici et là on l'a
vu à son époque manuel valls aujourd'hui
on peut en citer d'autres tout à fait
mais on a l'impression que c'est là ou
encore d'une certaine manière il ya même
un désaccord sur diagnostic vous avez
l'air de dire que la question première
celle qui hante tout un chacun c'est
celle de l'identité et qu'on verrait
cette identité de la france se dérober
alors que je crois que d'abord il ya
d'autres questions dans les sondages y
compris qui apparaissent en premier et
notamment la question du pouvoir d'achat
et notamment la question du changement
climatique et notamment la question des
services publics en particulier l'école
et l'hôpital donc ça ce sont des
questions qui sont centrales pour les
français et qui sont même devant les
questions de la crainte de nice de la
dissolution de notre de notre histoire
et la deuxième chose c'est que je pense
que il ya plusieurs façons de raconter
l'histoire ce qui m'ennuie c'est que
notre gauche nantes ne parle pas assez
de notre sort il ya eric zemmour qui
raconte d'une certaine manière ce qu'est
la france et moi je crois qu'il ya une
autre façon de raconter ce qu est la
france et qui est la france de la
conquête de légalité de l'égalité entre
tous la conquête de la laïcité la
conquête des libertés une donc une
france qui intègre sur des idées des
bases et des valeurs progressistes qui
sont toutes qui sont radicalement
opposée à celle d'eric zemmour est ce
que je crois c'est que la gauche devrait
absolument se saisir de cet enjeu du
récit dont du projet et de le porter
pour s'opposer à celui qui est proposé
par ces mots sans ça on ne va pas
descendre l'angoissent de quelle est
notre avenir commun il ya un avenir
commun mais il n'y a pas un avenir
commun sur la base du pétainisme par
contre il ya un avenir commun qui est
celui que qui a été celle de la france
depuis la révolution française avec des
hauts et des bas mais quand même de
beaux jérôme oui alors bon je pars hier
par rapport à ceux visés le geoffrey
lejeune tout à l'heure c'est vrai qu'à
force de défendre une thèse on finit par
y être identifiée mais c'est pas un sou
est particulièrement fier de mon travail
d des listes et c'est donc parfois je me
trompe
sondeurs qui se respecte mais c'est
c'est de le faire en toute bonne foi et
sans agenda particulier à la tête donc
par rapport à ce que vous dites
catherine tricot c'est quand même
comment dirais-je la vision de la
politique qui a chanté le move par
exemple en disant on peut construire un
récit comme cela on peut construire un
peuple cette espèce de constructivisme
politique qui caractérise désormais une
bonne partie de la gauche je crois que
ça n'a pas de réalité je suis heureuse
de la rencontre et cette partie de la
gauche et par contre eric zemmour je
l'entends lui il en construire le récit
mais non excusez moi c'est à dire que
ma méthode et non
mais c'est pas ça maintenant je me suis
belle fait comprendre je suis très
sceptique par rapport aux thèses de
chantal mouffe de conduire un peuple et
que l'on rend dans une stratégie
discursive santa le moof d'ailleurs est
probablement l'auteur le moins marxiste
qui existe actuellement sur le marché de
l'édition mais
je signale entre certaines ont saisi
dans cette émission peut se reporter sur
le site des merlus et d' interdit
d'interdire contact chantal bouffe et on
l'a lu avec attention parce qu'on m'a
dit bon une hauteur une année aux martys
toshiba
police
à cenon ce n'est pas eric zemmour qui
créent ou marine le pen d'ailleurs ou
quelqu'un d'autre qui créent leur art
par un récit sur l'immigration crée une
demande sociale cette demande sociale
elle existe très fortement depuis des
décennies la demande si la demande
d'arrêt l'immigration la demande d'une
politique sécuritaire et c'est celle que
quand je suis sorti je ne changerais
julio baptista excusez-moi de cette
confidence personnel mais moi je suis
sorti de sciences po d'études en lettres
dans la fin de la fin du musée 90 d'un
climat très marquée par la gauche morale
etc et quand je suis arrivé dans un mois
le premier incident sondages où je
travaillais il trouve qu'on travaille
beaucoup pour une année plusieurs allers
pas besoin de nombreuses à l'époque pour
les mairies communistes et donc je vais
y revenir les résultats de ces études
qui était fait je ne citerai pas les
noms et je voyais le mans j'étais
vraiment sorti de cet univers académique
avec l'idée qu'il y avait un sentiment
d'insécurité artificiellement entretenu
par des entrepreneurs politiques plus ou
moins douteux voire nauséabondes comme
on dit dans ces milieux là et je le
pensais plutôt en fait sincèrement et là
j'ai vu harry et les résultats de mes
enquêtes municipal des gens d'un député
de quartier il ya beaucoup de
populations d'origine immigrée extra
européenne et donc on avait des
majorités écrasantes de gens que nous
demander d'abord la sécurité après on
avait présenté ses études devant
d'emeric étaient des mairies de gauche
est généralement la direction communiste
et le maire nous disait mais vous savez
dans le secret de son bureau mais je
comprends pas moi j'ai pas de
commissariats ouvert après 20h et c'est
cette demande elle existe et elle était
souvent tus par les élites politiques de
gauche et de plus en plus et au fur et à
mesure c'est un cercle vicieux que la
gauche a perdu son électorat populaire
et s'est replié sur les classes moyennes
il a aussi fait une analyse il avait à
lille marxiste ses partisans mais nous
rouler des mondes - issu e du marxisme
au fur et à mesure cette gauche s'est
replié sur les classes moyennes et sur
un monde et c'est la sortie de
l'université notamment en sciences
sociales plus elle à nier ces demandes
sociales un moment donné les gens sont
allés voir mais je ne crois pas que
martine ce soit un pur sociologisme nous
soutient que je ne crois pas qu'ils
puissent sans qu'on puisse réduire des
choses comme ça c'est à dire des
catégories populaires elles pensent
comme elle gagne ça y pense ça et elles
sont comme ça etc je ne crois pas ce que
je pense qu'ils constituent et je ne
suis pas pourtant
une adepte de chantal mouche mais je
pense que ce qui constitue une classe
c'est quand même à la fois des réalités
partager concrètes mais c'est aussi un
projet est en l'occurrence ce que je
crois c'est que les tentatives
actuellement de fabien roussel pour
aller dans le sens de ce que vous dites
c'est à dire qu'il serait revenu le
secrétaire général du parti communiste
candidat à l'élection présidentielle je
le précise parce qu'il est quand même
très très très très très bas dans les
sondages et pourtant il ne cesse de
raconter que il va remettre tous les
sans papiers errent dans les avions pour
les renvoyer chez eux et à manifester
avec eric zemmour et le ministre de
l'intérieur auprès de la police non mais
si je m'excuse mais c'est ce qu'il pense
pouvoir apporter une réponse lui le
secrétaire général du parti communiste
en apportant ce type de réponse je
regrette mes seins il déstructure
complètement son camp c'est à dire que
ce qu'il est en train de faire c'est
qu'ils créent de du désarroi et de
l'incompréhension les gens de gauche ne
peuvent pas se retrouver dans ce
discours dans cette projection la quête
une projection
policière là ils viennent de refuser
et qu'il ya des vaudais violence
systémique dans la police va quand même
faut pas déconner quoi je veux dire de
colo secrétaire ou mais fait que le
secrétaire général du parti communiste
ne nous disent pas c'est extrêmement
troublant mon explosion je peux vous
dire c'est extrêmement troublant pour
les gens qui se retrouvent qui se
qu'habite les quartiers populaires qui
sont légèrement basané qui sont les
militants syndicaux etc enfin je veux
dire ils sont légères blues qui sauvent
des vies qui ont des gilets jaunes et
que c'était fini je vous interromps ont
fait une pause et on on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
vous avez annoncé des faillites en
cascade et une catastrophe économique la
reprise économique est elle finalement
plus dynamique que prévu le taux de
faillite il a diminué pourquoi tout
simplement parce que on a subventionné
les entreprises et cela depuis le départ
c'est à dire qu'on a remplacé du chiffre
d'affaires par de la dette on peut dire
qu'à la fin de l'année dernière
l'essentiel de la croissance conduite
pour cette année était déjà fait on peut
afficher des chiffres qui paraissent
mirobolant mais qui en fait sont très
loin de la réalité et des flux
économiques réels maintenant moi ce que
j'attends c'est la fin réelle des aides
de l'état et la fin réelle des aides de
l'état risque d'être un petit peu plus
compliqué l'économie va tellement bien
que pour faire face aux chocs me douter
de l'impact de la hausse du prix du
pétrole ou des carburants on revient
vite à la charge avec un chèque de 100
euros c'est peut-être que quand même il
ya des fragilités dont on nous parle pas
tout à fait mais qui inquiètent
bougrement
[Musique]
l'afrique c'est le continent qui
polluent le moins avec 4 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre que
demandez-vous que proposez vous
concrètement en afrique vous savoir qu'
un tiers du continent n'est pas
connectée à l'électricité la moitié de
la population n'a pas accès des
véhicules donc pour nous en afrique
lorsque nos parts de marché carbone pour
nous c'est pour sortir de la pauvreté
nous avons besoin de manière concrète
d'avoir des appuis en termes de
transferts de technologie est ce que
vous dénoncez une sorte de
discrimination climatiques voire à un
apartheid climatique si nous laissons
les choses se faire et si la voix de
l'afrique n'est pas entendue il est
clair que l'afrique va être discriminée
alors que nous représentons aujourd'hui
25% quasiment du processus de
négociation avec 50 pays sur 196 pays
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat avec jérôme
sainte-marie qui publie bloc populaire
aux éditions du cerf avec geoffroy le
jeune le directeur de valeurs actuelles
qui lui est l'auteur de zemmour
président aux éditions ring et avec
catherine tricot qui est la directrice
de la revue et du site regard la parole
était à vous et je fois le jeune vouliez
absolument réagir oui il est catherine
tripon il répondra catherine tricot
parce que je trouve comment dire très
très très touchant de votre volonté de
voir la gauche ressuscité et c'est
dommage je pense que les ressorts d'un
mail et je pense que les ressorts
n'existe pas et vous vous dites vous
disiez existe alors attendez je vais pas
voilà non mais parce que vous vous dites
que aujourd'hui fabien roussel vous vous
prenez les autres fumeurs ou celle qui
lui qui qui qui va sur un terrain sur
lequel on attend pas à savoir celui de
la défense des policiers la lutte contre
les clandestins etc en disant ça ne
marche pas il est très bas dans les
sondages ça veut donc dire qu'il n'ya
pas une attente de sécurité ou en tout
cas de discours ferme etc chez les gens
de gauche moi je vais te goures alors
pas moi je le jure schématise d'accord
mais ce que ce que je voudrais vous dire
c'est que quand vous quand vous quand
vous constatez le décalage entre le
discours de georges marchais il ya
trente ans et des dirigeants de la
gauche de toute la gauche a réuni depuis
des années 90 à savoir le l'adoration
diversiterre le la glorification de
l'immigration la glorification du droit
à la différence et c est que vous
constatez en parallèle de sa le passage
des classes populaires de la gauche à
laquelle elle était vraiment attaché
vers le front national puisque
aujourd'hui marine le pen est la
première candidate dans les chais les
ouvriers notamment et les catégories les
catégories populaires vous ne pouvez pas
ne pas voir que en abordant en
abandonnant ce discours ils ont laissé
partir une partie du peuple le petit
peuple comme on dit vers marine le pen
ar je connais assez bien l'histoire du
parti communiste et je peux vous dire
que quand même georges marchais était
son grand fossoyeur j'espère que quand
même georges marchais il prend le parti
communiste il est à plus de 20% quand il
quitte le parti comme eux il est à
bascule aussi bon il se fait doubler par
mitterrand c'est nous fassions non non
non non seulement dépouillé pour mille
il abdique et hilde des hardes
complètement ce que j'étais en train de
dire à propos des biens ou celle c'est à
dire que au lieu d'être sur des
positions de gauche y glisse il raconte
des choses personnellement mais ce sont
des positions de gauche initialement
mais non c'est pas ça brille c'est
absolument incompatible avec la gauche
mais non non non je m'excuse ce que je
veux dire c'est que je ne crois pas
qu'il ait de sujet de gauche et de
sujets de droit voilà je pense qu'il ya
des juges qu'il ya des sujets ils
doivent être politisée donc il doit y
avoir des réponses différentes qui sont
possibles donc sur la sécurité il ya des
réponses de gauche il ya des réponses de
droite voire même des réponses d'extrême
droite ce que je reproche c'est quand on
prend la sécurité qu'on lui accole une
réponse d'extrême droite mais c'est fait
le problème c'est que comment vous dites
vous ne pouvez pas imaginer à
l'immigration et pareil pour l'hôpital
et pareil pour les siens à parler clair
à partir du moment où sept français sur
dix considèrent que l'immigration est un
danger à partir du moment où ugly
français sur dix soutiennent la police
comment voulez vous construire un rebond
électoral sur le fait de dénoncer la
police plan b sa violence et de soi
disant systémique dont je pense
d'ailleurs qu'elle n'existe pas
d'aliment disant que l'immigration est
une chance pour la france c'est ça le
problème de la gauche alors je poserai
la question autrement si vous permettez
appartements dont sept français sur dix
soit huit français sur dix même
soutenait la votre la tribune des
militaires pour vous avez reproché
est ce qu'on peut parler d'une extrême
droite isation de la france certains ne
s'en privent pas ou c'est simplement les
français ont changé et il est à la
lumière d'un certain nombre d'événements
ils ont tout simplement changé évolué et
ils sont pas pour autant d'extrême
droite moi je pars car on est on vit
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
une espèce de crise d'avenir d'angoise
avec la crise climatique avec la
question de la place de la france dans
le monde on vient de vivre la pandémie
que tout ça crée une espèce de
d'inquiétude très très profonde et qu'on
reconnaît qu on retrouve notamment les
sondages dans la jeunesse l'expriment de
façon un peu très inquiétant très
alarmante et que donc grâce on dit cela
mais non mais non je ne le regrette mais
la france est le pays qui est le plus de
mariages mixtes donc je ne crois pas à
cette je ne crois pas que les français
sinon je dire non non il le plus
attentat aussi je veux dire elles
attendent des attentats c'est quand même
beau depuis un an non ça attendez que ce
que vous racontez maintenant mais sinon
pas au delà du point de vue du point de
vue de la société française la société
française n'est pas en train de se
monter et heureusement parce qu'on est
président a mis 6 à 8 millions de
musulmans en france que je veux dire que
que zemmour ait envie de raconter qu'il
faut se préparer à faire la lutte la
guerre etc à préparer une guerre de
religion je regrette je ne me vois pas
du tout et je pense c'est pour ça qu'il
n'ira pas à l'elysée et que même il sera
derrière le pen lui viennent au mois
elle a compris qu'il fallait dans les
mondes les émaux une seconde par des
mois c'est ça
si si l'islamisme et une angoisse pour
l'opinion princesse de jeu nous a déjà
non ce que je crois c'est que ce qui est
une angoisse et donc qu'est-ce que nous
sommes quel pays nous sommes et encore
une fois ce que je pense ben oui ce que
je pour ça que je crois que le le
discours de la gauche qui est un
discours d'égalité d'égalité de tous est
un discours qui est un discours inclusif
et qui permet de répondre à cette
angoisse je ne suis pas en train de nier
les angoisses maintenant j'ai pas en
train de gilles binya non non non ce que
je dis c'est qu'il ya deux façons d'y
répondre en a qu'une qui dit ah oui vous
avez raison d'être angoissé d'ailleurs
regardez il mange du couscous ils font
ils marient porteront un foulard sur la
tête et c'est
d'ailleurs ya et d'ailleurs ils portent
des prénoms extrêmement bizarre et
d'ailleurs il ya des attentats etc et
c'est donc à une partie qu'ils racontent
ça il ya une autre partie dont je fais
partie qui dit la grandeur de la france
a été d'intégrer toutes ses vagues
d'immigration sont nés le pays qui
intègre le plus d'immigrés dans le monde
avec les états unis et que nous avons
avons su le faire sur la base de la
conquête de l'égalité de tous et
notamment au travers des services
publics d'un état fort intégrateurs donc
je crois alors gérez-vous cette marque
pas je vais essayer d'exprimer là mais
la méthode que j'ai dessus dans mon
bouquin puis en général mais justement
je vais partir malheureusement même
tricot de votre développement je vous
trouve d'un idéalisme écoutez c'est pas
un défaut et d'un idéalisme oui sauf que
l'idéalisme ça c'est un immense défaut
vous dire que tu sais que quelque temps
on se prévaut de valeur on en vient à
déprécier ce que vous venez de faire ce
qu'ils ne le partage pas en l'occurrence
une bonne partie du peuple français que
vous décrivez comme des gens qui
n'aiment pas le couscous etc et donc
comme des racistes en fait dire
l'idéalisme encore une fois on a ça
maintenant j'ai un territoire où m
impitoyablement oui enfin bon il ya
comme des impitoyables mans au
manichéisme me semble-t-il notre jeu
mais de dire le contraire c'est le pays
qui est le plus intégrateurs et de
mariages mixtes et que je mets
les jeunes alger promet me plairait bien
les fous je fais 40 15 ans je vais
prendre le problème de mon point de vue
c'est à l'envers c'est à la base mais
pourquoi d'où viennent mes conclusions
pas d'un jugement de valeur sur ce que
pensent les uns et les autres mais sur
le constat de ce qu'il pense de ce
qu'ils expriment dans les urnes dans la
rue et dans les sondages dans les urnes
tout simplement vous avez effectivement
comment dirais-je la gauche que vous
vous exalté est devenu très très
minoritaires dans les sondages
aujourd'hui avant cas au printemps avant
le avant le comment dirais-je l'éruption
de d'eric zemmour lorsqu'il veut une
seule offre unique dans le courant
nationaliste on va appeler ça comme ça
et bien 50 % parfois des ouvriers et 30
% des employés jusqu'à 40 % parfois et
bien et sait comment dirais-je
choisissez dans les intentions de vote
en tout cas marine le pen 1 je suis allé
chercher y compris dans les ouvrages
consacrés au parti communiste dont un
des collaborateurs de
ou vice président de regard martelly
lelubre âge du parti likoud c'est bien
il ya beaucoup de tableaux sur la
sociologie électorale à la fin et c'est
j'allais chercher qu'elle était là pour
la pénétration du vote communiste chez
les ouvriers je crois qu'on n'a jamais
atteint un tel niveau au premier tour au
premier tour 50 % ont ça s'apparente à
un vote de classe d'une intensité
incroyable
il faut essayer de comprendre ou alors à
moins d'un moins d'en déduire que les
ouvriers les prolos aurait des
mentalités comment dirais-je moindre de
moindre valeur morale que les classes
moyennes la fonction publique qui sont
quand même le terreau de la gauche
dernière chose moi j'étais également
frappé parce que je suis allé suivre y
compris pour slogan de magazines en
l'occurrence mais je suis allé suivre
une vingtaine de rassemblements des
gilet jaune à paris et notamment dans en
novembre décembre la gauche était
absente je connais assez bien l'extrême
gauche et la gauche parisienne et
généralement quand je vais assister une
manifestation est partie de mes péchés
mignons et bien je reconnais des figures
que parfois j'ai connu depuis 30 ans
là au pied de l'arc de triomphe je ne
connaissais personne et quand il
interroge les gens c'étaient des anciens
électeurs de marine le pen beaucoup
d'abstentionnistes et quelques anciens
des lecteurs de mélenchon en rupture de
ban donc cette césure s'il voulait l ai
pas inventés par un entrepreneur par une
chaîne de télévision ou par un média
fussent valeurs actuelles futile et
valeurs actuelles pardon et b c'est
quelque chose qui vient de la base et
qui ensuite dont on doit rendre compte
dernière je finirai par an par l'ats je
pense qu'on peut pas atteindre non plus
abstrait ça sera peut-être la nuance que
j'ai parfois avec sur le jeune c'est que
on a quand même une structuration en
classe qui est très forte la gauche elle
a aujourd'hui une sociologie qui est
très simple c'est le parti de la dépense
publique c'est à dire les fonctionnaires
les professeurs notamment je le sais que
je suis issue d'une longue série de
professeurs est effectivement et tout
bois était plus ou moins à gauche mais
effectivement c'est le parti la dépense
publique
carmax le radon est très bien l'origine
de convenir qu'ils sont à l'origine de
revenir les dépenses publiques on peut
dire les services publics oui mais donc
on est sous la risée 11e par cette façon
de raconter les choses n'étaient
autorisés électoralement à l'origine de
son revenu moyens d'existence sociale
puisque en ce moment beaucoup parlent de
pétain ce que je trouve très intéressant
de se souvenir c'est que en
1944 il y avait des centaines de
milliers de parisiens qui a clamé pétain
et
d'alcool c'est entièrement faux d'accord
les français n'ont pas clamé pétain
l'année d'après et l'année en ayant non
plus quand le quand générale or là
arrive c'est renversement des s'en tient
à ce que je veux dire par là - coûté
football a lille on a rien pour sujet
les bains et que je crois connaître
cette histoire mais apparemment ce n'est
pas le débat de ce soir exactement ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que de
cultiver les passions tristes de la
france c'est tout à fait possible la
france a été très profondément
antisémite la france a dénoncé il ya eu
des centaines de milliers de lettres de
dénonciation pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et la france elle est capable
d'autre chose elle est capable de ça et
elle est capable de faire de ce dur se
redresser comme elle l'a fait à la
sortie de la guerre c'est à dire
d'inventer le service public d'inventer
les pros les avancées sociales qu'elle a
fait d'intégrer tout le monde est ce que
je vais dire ce que c'est pour ça que je
pense que contrairement à vous je crois
que le discours ça construit le peuple
qu'est ce qu'on raconte sur quoi on se
met d'accord qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
ensemble et aujourd'hui moi je veux bien
qu'on constate qu' il ya des gens qui
ont peur des immigrés que idiots ils
veulent plus de flics et cetera et
cetera moins ce que je dis c'est que ce
avec ça nous allons vers une un
déchirement de notre société et en plus
en plus que c'est un déchirement notre
société je pense ça ne nous permet pas
de nous préparer aux à l'avenir c'est à
dire le réchauffement climatique le
montée des inégalités la question de
préparer la transformation de la france
pour le nouveau siècle etc tout ça c'est
à côté du sujet on pourra toujours
changer les prénoms des enfants à la
naissance cela ne fera aucune solution
pour ces enjeux majeurs pour pour
avancer justement j'aimerais que vous
m'éclairer sur la faiblesse du vote
écologiste à chaque fois on nous promet
à chaque fois que les écologistes font
une percée dans une élection
généralement l'élection européenne mais
il ya eu aussi aux municipales dernière
on promet un avenir radieux à la
formation écologiste est aujourd'hui
dans les sondages tout ça n'existe pas
je disais les 30% que se partagent les
sept candidates déclarées de gauche on
may a dit que jadot dedans donc c'est
véritablement résiduelles comment
expliquez-vous que alors est ce que
c'est devenu un combat ou d'impression
générationnel le combat en faveur du vin
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique on a l'impression que ça
n'intéresse que les gens moins de 25 ans
alors bon je veux moi je veux bien qu'on
ne parle pas de sociologie du vote mais
enfin s'il ya un vote qu'à une
sociologie ses liens les écologistes moi
j'en ai une analyse assez simple alors
je reste dans mon système de pensée un
qu'il faut c'est bien qu'il est
réducteur mais faut il vaut mieux ça que
l'éclectisme bon on finit par être
impliqué tout par toutes sortes de
secteurs différents le psychologique et
autres ce que je constate si vous voulez
c'est qu'effectivement l'électorat
l'électorat vert il est très puissant
d'ailleurs dans des élections
intermédiaires où il n'y a pas d'enjeux
de pouvoir et où l'abstention est très
forte c'est quand même le
caractéristiques et en les municipales
c'est très trompeur parce qu'en fait
c'est souvent à l'issue de négociations
et de têtes de listes de gauche
l'exemple de marseille est parti comme
un révélateur mais pendant les
européennes le seuil avait beaucoup
d'intentions d'ailleurs cette même une
abstention massive est effectivement
vous avez cette population diplômés
relativement jeunes des villes centres
pour parler comme lui
ça ressemble beaucoup vous savez un
concept cher à mme et m marxiste ses
terres la petite bourgeoisie la petite
bourgeoisie artiste et comme toute
petite bourgeoisie dont un problème ces
gens là parce qu'ils ont un statut très
intermédiaire ils ont un statut ou qui
ne leur permet pas de se situer
clairement dans le conflit principal
dire le conflit entre le bloc élitaire
et le bloc populaire ces gens là souvent
n'aime pas du tout vaincrons mais ils
ont pris un soin extrême à paris à ne
pas se mêler aux mouvements des gilet
jaune il déteste on peut pas me parler
de prolophobie parfois voyez il déteste
ces gens là ils les trouvent
réactionnaire enfin bref ça va pas du
tout qu'on ne fait pas développer ça ça
a été fait sans foi mais en tout cas ils
ont ils ont voté par leurs pieds c'est
par le fait que pendant que ça se
passait en bas de chez eux contre le
pouvoir de macron il n'était pas là mais
lors pas là du tout j'ai pu le vérifier
et donc ces gens là ils ont du mal à se
situer dans le conflit principal dont le
conflit de classe principale me
semble-t-il et qui est du coup
ils vont sur des thèmes qui leur permet
d'y échapper et puis à la présidentielle
bon ben là on verra bien déjà ils sont
leurs scores et limité parce que là tout
le monde va voter ou presque est en tout
cas 80% des français et puis les enjeux
matériels eux prennent le dessus
une des raisons de l'impuissance des
écologistes c'est justement leur
caractéristique d'être d'un entre-deux
social qui les empêche de se situer
quand les choses deviennent sérieuses je
vois le jeune j'ai rien à ajouter à ça
c'est vrai que en fait on constate des
percées systématiquement des élections
sans enjeu en réalité et même sans être
méchant avec des gens que j'aime bien
mais en réalité il ya eu des percées
aussi conceptuel souverainiste dans les
années dans aux élections européennes de
2,99
si je ne m'abuse de villiers et parce
que ça que je vois les épopées
européennes de philippe de villiers 94
exactement et 99 mèl et marie france
garaud et marie france garaud évidemment
et ils ont obtenu beaucoup de députés et
c est en réalité voilà il ya moins de
gens qui votent tout à coup il suffit
d'un carnet une idée bien aidé
rassembler des gens qui en fait sont pas
forcément des convaincus mais qui se
font plaisir parce qu'en réalité il n'ya
pas d'enjeu moi je vais pas aller
beaucoup plus loin dans l'analyse mais
mais je vais peut-être ajouter une seule
chose c'est que vous avez raison de dire
que dans les enquêtes d'opinion
sur des priorités des français
aujourd'hui le pouvoir d'achat et
l'écologie arrive bien loin devant
l'insécurité et l'immigration je vois
les mêmes enquêtes d'opinion sauf qu'au
moment d'aller voter pour la
présidentielle cessez jamais le cas la
motivation du vote avait toujours lié à
des sujets identitaires quasiment alors
ça donne donne parfois si quasiment il
ya eu des moments où c'est la base de
l'école buisson là effectivement
mais la vérité c'est que combien son
procédé sarkozy sarkozy réussisse et il
n'y a pas à gagner à chaque fois mais
ces
gardes à challans pouvoir d'achat
maintenant ça veut dire qu'ils ont déjà
refusé mon bonheur effectivement elle a
fait 50% c'est la première fois qu'un
candidat de droite faisait 50 % chez les
ouvriers exactement second tour et moi
je sais où d'ailleurs le vote le jean
marie le pen a fait son plus mauvais
c'est pour ça que je ne néglige pas du
tout la question sociale je pense
qu'elle est extrêmement important que tu
d'accord sur les intérêts matériels
c'est extrêmement important et les
intérêts identitaire sarkozy rouge gagne
avec le kärcher et le travailler plus
pour gagner plus et la défiscalisation
des heures sup mais là où je ne suis pas
du tout d'accord avec vous c'est que
vous racontez une france qui est votre
france rêver et vous êtes la preuve
éclatante de la raison pour laquelle la
gauche ne réussit plus à parler en tout
cas à retrouver un élan électorale c'est
pas du tout une critique c'est que vous
avez droit de dire ce que vous pensez
est ce que vous souhaitez c'est votre
droit le plus strict sauf que des gens
ne veulent pas comme vous en fait en
réalité et donc à partir du moment où
sur tous les sujets qui sont des disques
et qui vous met mal à l'aise que vous
n'aimez pas où vous coûte rouge et
secondaire si vous décidez de ne pas en
parler c'est normal que les gens se
désintéressent de vous et je vous
garanti qu au moment d'aller voter la
question de howlett mans il ya quelques
exceptions je suis bien d'accord avec ça
ma commande est une guerre mais mais
mais mais il ya assez peu de cas où le
sujet la question des migrations de
l'islam n'est pas présent pour du
domaine présidentiel bon alors ma ce que
je dis c'est que je suis dit exactement
le contraire fait qu'il n'y avait pas de
sujet de gauche ou de droite il ya
simplement une réponse de gauche ou de
droite à chacun de préciser donc donc
non ce que je pensais que la gauche ne
contournent esquive ces sujets là parce
qu'elles pensent qu'ils sont
défavorables alors que moi je crois que
est la gauche a intérêt à y aller mais
pas à y aller pour apporter des réponses
de droite qui perturbe tout le monde l'a
de la question que pose est est-ce qui
était la question de l'écologie ce que
je crois c'est que ça serait réducteur
de penser que seuls les électeurs de le
élevés sont des électeurs écologistes
dire qu'en fait je pense que quand même
l'écologie je pense que par exemple le
jean luc mélenchon acheter une campagne
très écologiste en 2017 je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il a un peu perdu là
c'est à dire qu'on ne sait plus très
bien jean luc mélenchon il est le
candidat de quoi c'est à dire qu'il est
dans les mutations de jean luc mélenchon
dans son parcours personnel qui est
assez peu arrimé à une organisation donc
en fait on suit les évolutions
intellectuelle de jean luc mélenchon qui
font que ça a évolué et là le ski était
franchement très central dans son
discours en 2017 notamment la question
de la préparation de la transformation
écologique aujourd'hui est assez
ténue et en tout cas peu articulée à la
question de la transformation globale de
la société et je pense que les
écologistes perdre parce qu'aujourd'hui
il veut dire si l'écologie c'est de
supprimer les abattoirs contre les époux
enfin pour empêcher la maltraitance
animale je pense que ça fera pas la
maille du tout pour l'élection
présidentielle donc c'est une faiblesse
s'il ne porte pas un discours écologiste
au niveau d'un discours globalisant que
par exemple quelqu'un comme delphine
batho a su faire lors de la primaire des
écologistes souhaitent été assez radical
je lis pas que je partageais tout ce
qu'elle disait mais elle elle était
cohérente et globale et je pense que
il ya une espèce d'hésitation soi disant
pour rassembler large pour ratisser
large la force de rassembler large et
ratisser large ne disent pas grand chose
et jean luc mélenchon on sait pas très
bien où il en est tout à fait sur cette
question écologistes mais en tout cas on
ne peut pas raisonner simplement pour
savoir où on est l'écologie sur
simplement le vote est 2e et dernière
question
qu'est ce qui sépare encore les
électeurs des républicains qui donc
demain s'apprêtent à voter soit pour
xavier bertrand soit pour valérie
pécresse ou pour michel barnier pas
forcément dans les mêmes proportions
d'ailleurs et ceux qui votent marine le
pen ou éventuellement même eric zemmour
dont on avait pour çà a maintenant que
peut-être allait-il se présenter à une
primaire des républicains s'il y en
avait une je prendre des études
anciennes pour le coup de
main en presqu'une dizaine d'années que
j'ai fait dans un livre pour le figaro
magazine il allait tester des mesures du
programme de marine le pen à l'époque
c'est des mesures il y avait trois
mesures sur l'or dans le domaine
régalien commandes immigration sécurité
trois mesures dans le domaine économique
et social sur le régalien c'est à dire
sur l'immigration l'islam la sécurité
pour aller vite les positions à l'époque
des sympathisants ça devienne des
sympathisants ump je pense non pas l air
était quasiment les mêmes que celles du
des sympathisants ça devait être fn ou
orange et par où on en était aujourd'hui
il arrive même sur un sujet que les
sympathisants de droite exprime france
et suivait des choses plus radical
encore que les sympathisants le pénis
qui ont d'autres chats à fouetter en
fait et donc vous avez pour qui ces
acquis et c&a versement à l'époque c'est
encore la question de l'euro vous savez
cette l'époque philippot au front
national et donc il y avait la question
de l'euro devant lui et c'est là sur ces
questions là par contre l'électorat de
droite classique se distingue
radicalement de l'électorat qui est
d'ailleurs l'électorat fn doit aussi une
énorme différence entre sociologique
pour le coup encore une fois entre les
deux aujourd'hui vous avez encore ceux
ci qui existe d'autant plus qu'une bonne
partie des sympathisants de l air a une
bonne opinion de l'exécutif ça c'est une
différence majeure actuellement la les
sympathisants qui s'oppose le plus c'est
pour ça que je crois encore bon niçois
de bloc contre bloc c'est se pose le
plus à maquereau et à son gouvernement
c'est les sympathisants du rn plus que
ceux de la france a soumises du parti
communiste mais quand je demandais ce
que vous faites confiance pas confiance
en question toute bête las une
opposition radicale répétés etc la
gauche très souvent vous avez 30 à 40%
des sympathisants écologistes ou
sympathisants socialistes n'est ce pas
les sympathisants des françaises
soumises qui trouve que finalement c'est
pas si mal ce que fait macroscope contre
les risques fait qu'à ce texte c'est ça
paraît bizarre comme ça mais ça se
constate pas en permanence on ne
bougeait de l'école de comporter
quelques crédits à ces données et
inversement les la droite c'est pour ça
qu'elle a du mal à savoir où elle habite
et pour ça qu'elle est très vulnérable à
des opéras comme celle d'eric zemmour
c'est que les hésitations des leaders de
la droite ne tient pas à une femme de
terrain quelconque faiblesse de
caractère ou un vide idéologique ça
tient au fait qu'ils sont élus par des
gens qui sont très divisés là dessus
très souvent vous avez 50 % au moins des
sympathisants et l'eire qui disent que
castex est un beau premier ministre voit
fait manuel macron est un beau présent
la république donc vous avez
effectivement cette grande difficulté de
positionnement pour la présentielle de
la droite classique et on ait
l'impression sera de ma dernière
question que sur l'europe en revanche
les français sont inamovibles
il aimerait bien qu'on la change cette
europe elle répond pas une pierre moinot
veut mais au fond venez pas question
d'en sortir on n'a pas du tout envie de
se retrouver nez tout petit isolé je me
trompe je crois que c'est un c'est un
piège électoral cette question sert que
je ne sais pas du tout ce que donnerait
un référendum sur la question du fric
sites en france je pense qu'il serait
perdue par les partisans du président et
en même temps le dernier exemple qu'on a
eue c'était 2005 et le messin sceller
les partisans du non qui ont gagné donc
je en revanche ce que tout le monde a
compris en tout cas dans les gens qui
sont les plus souverainiste ou les plus
anti européen c'est que le livre mieux
pour en parler c'est vrai parce que
électoralement c'est extrêmement piégeux
marine le pen se casse la gueule
pardonnez moi l'expression dans le débat
d'entre deux tours avec emmanuel macron
sur la question monétaire kelly à la
question de l'europe eric zemmour qui
est un souverainiste forcené genre ne le
connaît bien il pourra il pourra
confirmer est aujourd'hui en train de
rentrer en campagne en disant je ne
change rien je ne touche rien laissez
moi juste m'occuper de l'immigration
parce qu'il a compris qu'en fait c'était
très compliqué et quant à quant au
tenant de l'ailé souverainiste de gauche
de la même manière se font assez discret
sur le sujet mélenchon les quelques
années par l'aide de sortir des traités
on l'entend rapidement sur la question
en fait en réalité je pense que et
honnêtement c'est du doigt mouillé c'est
pas une intuition sais pas c'est pas une
analyse de son âge mais je pense que
qu'on peut reprocher beaucoup de choses
à l'europe mais lille inconsciemment la
prix là là là là comment dire la prise
de conscience du fait que si on en sort
ça peut être pire voilà donc c'est très
compliqué et c'est donc une menace un
piège et électoralement je penserai
aucun intérêt à y aller c'est avant tout
le monde se fait très discret pmp creux
ouais moi j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
quand même une conscience que la france
toute petite ne peux pas répondre aux
enjeux qui sont devant nous et c'est
pour ça que je ne crois pas à l'étroit
test du prisme d'eric zemmour ou de
l'extrême droite des ânes manière c'est
que je pense que les enjeux il ya une
conscience que les enjeux se joue à des
échelles et avec des faits d'une manière
plus inclusive plus large et que cette
entrée par on va s'en sortir tout seul
dans notre coin je pense que la pandémie
il viennent de montrer le réchauffement
climatique le monde était la preuve que
justement le
nom lamouri lapandry un autre camp
aujourd'hui que si on vaccine pas toute
l'humanité on s'en sortira peut-être
l'hiver quand vous avez quand vous avez
des sujets sur ces boîtes avait
d'hésiter bien sur intermat pour
l'envolée des masques c'est donc chez mr
donc c'était c'était consternant c'est
ce n'était pas la solution de son équipe
contre des italiens en revanche ce qui a
été une solution c'est que tous les
chercheurs du monde entier ont partagé
la connaissance le le génome de duke au
vide et que c'est grâce à ça qu'on a pu
trouver si rapidement un vaccin et que
tant qu'on ne tiendra pas tout le monde
on va pas s'en sortir et son nom mais
qui obligeait zone euro ont mis six à
avoir ça à voir avec le fait avec
l'interdépendance avec la conscience que
nous sommes interdépendants et ça ce
n'est pas imposé ça c'est une position
qui n'est pas compatible avec la
fermeture ou prenez l'un l'extrême
droite c'est bien mais alors que dans
les propositions économiques
l'angleterre qui vient de faire le le
site vient de piquer le couple à 55
milliards non mais voilà mais c'est tout
seul ils ont été plus forts que nous
c'est quand même assez intéressant les
services publics comme jamais auparavant
nettement augmenté les salaires
moyens je vous souhaite d'aller en
angleterre c'est exactement l'inversé
que j'entends dire je dire que la
situation anglaise au quotidien ne cesse
de se dégrader les gens sont extrêmement
malheureuse entre les gens les
journalistes ont fait montre qu'il est
l'heure je vous arrête la cogestion
l'émission s'est terminée merci tous les
trois d'y avoir participé
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]